- All right.
Hi, good morning everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
I hope you guys have been enjoying
this year's AWS re:Invent thus far
Thanks to AWS for giving
us the opportunity
to speak a little bit
about ScyllaDB here today.
And of course, I would like also
to express my deepest gratitude
to both SAS and Freshworks,
both for their continued
partnership as well
as taking the time to
share a bit of their story
with us here today.
All of which you are going
to hear about here shortly.
My name is Felipe,
and I work as a technical
director at ScyllaDB.
So, just to set the scene
here real quick, I want
to briefly recap the primary
challenges teams face when
they try to scale their
data-intensive applications.
These are applications
that require extremely high throughputs
with fast and consistent response times,
often within single-digit milliseconds
or lower for their tail latencies.
As data-intensive applications scale
and becomes critical for your business,
the primary core challenge is ensuring
their consistent performance.
As you scale,
conventional database systems
become increasingly sensitive
to traffic fluctuations,
which yes, you can try
to best by throwing more
money at the problem,
but that quickly becomes unsustainable
in the longer term.
And this is really the context
Where ScyllaDB fits in.
ScyllaDB is the database for applications
that require predictable
performance at scale.
Our architecture is specifically designed
to eliminate performance bottlenecks
that conventional database
systems struggle with at scale.
Rather than compensating
with more hardware,
ScyllaDB's close-to-the-metal architecture
is built to maximize the performance
of underlying infrastructure.
That's why organizations trust ScyllaDB
to power their most critical applications.
With ScyllaDB,
a small three-node cluster
running on top of AWS CC2
is capable of sustaining
millions of operations per second
with predictable single-digit
millisecond latencies.
Even as workloads grow and fluctuate,
this efficiency does not
just improve performance
but considerably reduce
infrastructure costs,
giving you headroom
to scale your most demanding
data-intensive applications.
So, how do I know whether
ScyllaDB is a database
that's a good fit for me?
First, if your current response
times are unpredictable,
especially when your tail
latencies are starting
to violate your SLAs,
and your teams keep getting
paged at 3:00 AM just for you
to babysit the database.
Second, if your database cannot keep up
with throughput demands,
particularly during peak or spike traffic,
or when you are forced to overprovision
just to stay ahead of a predictable load
because your system lacks true elasticity.
And third, your database
expansion is spiraling,
and adding more nodes, replicas,
or caches has become the only way
to mask the performance issues,
which ends up driving
your costs out of control.
If any of those three points,
or a combination of
these, resonates to you,
then you may want to
check out on ScyllaDB.
So, this chart on this slide demonstrates
our user base spectrum,
where the Y-axis represents throughput
and the X-axis represents latencies.
As you can see, the
largest cluster of users
really live in the top-left-hand side,
with workloads ranging close
to a million operations per second,
requiring between single-digit
to less than 20-millisecond
P99 response times.
Now, why ScyllaDB?
Our highly available
architecture allows teams
to confidently run mission-critical
applications at scale.
We are built first and foremost
with high-performance
transactional workloads in mind,
while we still support
real-time analytical use cases
that need fast access to operational data.
And, more recently this year,
with our recent native vector search,
ScyllaDB becomes a unified AI platform
built for performance.
ScyllaDB can start
and serve massive volumes of
data while using fewer nodes,
reducing infrastructure costs
and operational overhead.
It's also designed to
avoid vendor lock-in,
give you the flexibility to
run your workloads on-prem,
in any cloud, or in a hybrid environment,
and effectively allowing
you to serve data closer
to your users when it matters.
Elasticity is also built deep,
very deep in our architecture.
We allow cluster to scale with
demand, eliminating the waste
of permanently overprovision
infrastructure,
so you get predictable
performance during traffic spikes
and cost efficiency the rest of the time.
So, how are organizations
using ScyllaDB today?
Beyond SAS and Freshworks,
at last year's re:Invent,
I had the opportunity
to speak along with TripAdvisor
here at this very same re:Invent
who shared how ScyllaDB powers their
real-time machine learning
system for recommendations.
We also have companies like Discord,
who use ScyllaDB at massive scale
to connect millions of users
in real-time around the world.
Disney Plus and Hulu
are relying on ScyllaDB
to power their media streaming services.
ScyllaDB, having supported the Super Bowl
for actually many years in a row now.
We've got that far. Yeah.
And of course, most of the
organizations listed here
actually also run ScyllaDB within AWS,
which makes it perfect for
me to talk a little bit about
our existing partnership with AWS.
ScyllaDB has been, for many
years, an AWS ISV partner,
where we've partnered
together in demonstrating
the superior price/performance
of their EC2 I4i and I7i
instances ahead of their launch,
as well as the superior
Graviton performance,
also in AWS EC2.
We are a Graviton-ready partner,
and we have two listings
in the AWS Marketplace.
We have ScyllaDB Enterprise
for users who want to run
and self-manage their
own database deployments,
and we have ScyllaDB Cloud,
our fully managed
database-as-a-service offering.
So, with that, let me
switch over to Brian Jones,
Senior Manager of Software
Development at SAS,
who is going to tell us a little bit
about SAS's real-time
personalization story.
Brian, thank you so much
for sharing your story with us today,
and with that, the floor is yours.
- All right.
Thank you, Felipe, and
thank you, everyone,
for coming to this presentation today.
So, the first thing I wanna
do is talk about the Big Game.
So, you're sitting down
watching the Big Game,
and suddenly there's
a break in the action,
and now you get an advertisement,
and it happens to be the same commercial
you've already seen in previous break,
and that's very annoying for you.
Why does that happen?
Well, they're probably
not a customer of SAS.
At SAS, we've been delivering
digital advertising
during live sporting events
like football, soccer, tennis, rugby.
Since 2014,
we have a robust ad-tech
platform seamlessly integrating
with your own data workflows
and partner ecosystem.
Good ad decisions require
us to activate data quickly,
which improves the outcomes
for both viewers, advertisers,
and broadcasters.
In plain terms,
the core of video advertising
is composed of a few parts.
The first of these is ad decisions.
When we receive an ad request,
we need to make a decision
quickly about what to serve,
and that response in video advertising
uses the IAB VAST standard,
which will include some
playback signals or events.
So, as the advertisement is played out,
these signals come back
to SAS, other partners,
and those become then
part of the reporting
that broadcasters and
advertisers will utilize.
And finally, especially
for video-on-demand,
optimization can happen
where you can choose
how many ads to show or
how long a break should be
for individual users.
So, this picture is
from inside the Ocracoke Lighthouse.
You can take a look inside of
there during summer months,
and like the steps to
summit this lighthouse,
there are a few challenges
in digital video advertising
I want to discuss.
So, first you need to scale to
support large traffic spikes,
integrate with the rest of the ecosystem,
and make advertising
relevant to each viewer.
So, at SAS, we help organizations
do amazing things with the data,
and we've been doing it
for nearly five decades.
SAS is a leader in data and AI,
with headquarters in Cary, North Carolina.
Our focus is on helping people to use data
and AI responsibly and effectively.
SAS 360 Match delivers decisions at scale
for our customers around the world.
So, these are some of the
numbers, billions of impressions,
video ads, programmatic bid request,
and all delivered with low
latency and high availability.
So, this image captures part
of the new user interface
for SAS 360 Match that I and
my team have been working on
at SAS.
It is a first party ad server
delivered as
software-as-a-service application
to publishers, broadcasters,
retailers, financial institutions,
and we have clients like desktop browsers,
mobile applications, connected
TV, and many other platforms.
So, I work on essentially
all aspects of this product:
R&D, operations, security, governance,
legal, audit, et cetera, et cetera.
So, if you have questions,
come talk to me afterwards.
So, what kind of data
do we usually have when
we're making a decision?
So, we have personal data,
like where are you, your interests,
maybe some data that you use
to sign up for a service,
registration data.
There could be analytics or scoring data
that's also attached to your identity.
Additionally, there's contextual data.
Amazon has spoken about this
for a couple of years now,
using AI to grab contextual
data from video streams
in advance or in live.
So, you have episode data, break data,
also recent ad-serving history data.
Then we also can incorporate other data.
So, there could be product
data or potentially offer data.
So, from all of this data, audiences
and segments are created
that appeal to advertisers.
So, there are many methods available
to provide data for decisions.
An ad request may provide this data.
The data could come from
an external web service.
For example, if you need
to get the current weather
for a location based on geo,
that data is fetched,
cached for a brief period of
time and used for that request.
You can also reference
data that we hold in memory
or is stored in a persistent data store.
And any of this data could
refer to other identifiers,
which we'll load more data for you.
And recently, as of earlier this year,
we introduced the concept of datasets,
which is basically a
hierarchy of identifiers
where we evaluate each
set of data independently
to determine what should be served.
So, let's dig a little
bit into an ad break.
So, when a video stream is
approaching an ad break,
there will be a signal within the stream.
SCTE is a type of signaling,
indicating that a break is coming soon
and we need to make an ad request.
That ad request is usually templated.
It doesn't usually have very much data,
a couple of things at most, usually.
And we'll receive this,
and then we'll need to make a
decision about what to serve.
And so, we will return
a VAST-formatted XML template response.
And inside of this, we'll
have a number of these events,
which I mentioned earlier,
like impression, view,
various standard quartiles,
those sorts of signals.
And this is an example of what
the break actually looks like
to our software.
It's a series of requests.
In this example, we have
a duration server request.
It's asking for a duration of 180 seconds.
It says that this is the
particular break identifier.
This is like a pseudo-random identifier.
It'll recycle after a
couple months, probably.
Then we have an identifier
of some name for a visitor,
so in this case SVID.
And then, after this ad request
returns the VAST response,
the service-side ad insertion,
or the player device,
whatever, was begin making
these count requests.
These are all the events that
were in the VAST response
to begin with for all the quartiles
that we mentioned before.
So then, how do we make a decision?
Let's dive a little bit through that.
So, if we've never seen a
request from a user before,
from a visitor, we're gonna
need to start a session.
So, we will start the session
usually with an identifier
that's given to us,
but sometimes we'll need to generate one.
We'll then load data if we
have it for the individual,
if we've got data to load for them,
including all of their
previous history that we need
to enforce other business rules.
And then we can begin
processing the actual request.
So, we'll activate more data.
So, supertags, these are in-memory data,
sometimes persisted data from identifiers,
usually coming from expansions of things
that are inside of the request itself.
Then, other identifiers may be loaded.
Remember the products and offers
that we talked about earlier.
Connectors are the
things where you can talk
to any HTTP web service
to load more data, still,
you can also talk to SAS
Intelligent Decisioning.
Then, we need to make a decision
so the customer can
introduce prioritization
based on their needs for their inventory.
SAS can perform optimizations,
as well as targeting via Boolean logic,
on all of this key-value
data that we have in hand.
And if the customer is using it,
we can talk to OpenRTB SSP
for open web creatives,
or they can make use of
direct bookings in the system
as well.
So, once we have selected the creative,
we'll render response again
from the VAST template
for video advertising.
We'll serve that and record
this decisions, one or more,
as well as metrics that
need to be generated.
So, providing the best decision
in the moment also means
that we support the viewers, for example,
by preventing the exposure
to the same advertiser
or ad too often,
ensuring that industry
and government regulations are followed,
and respecting the privacy rules
and regulations our
customers must adhere to.
So, at SAS, we approach things differently
than many other players
in the digital video advertising industry.
SAS does not collect
and aggregate data across customers,
as others in the advertising
industry often do.
So, the broadcasters have
control over their data
and with whom that data shared.
We provide our customers with the tools
that are open to integration
and extension to fit their needs.
Both performance and availability
matter not just for users,
but also advertisers and our customers.
How do we scale our access to data?
We require, this is a requirement,
that the database have low-latency reads.
It must have high
availability, data redundancy,
and predictable cost.
But there's not enough time
during this cycle of ad request,
to fetch the data, make use of it,
and make the changes
and write them back out.
So, we introduce some other concepts.
We activate the data on session start.
We write changes to the
data, when necessary.
And this reduces the interactions
necessary for sessions
that are routed, based on,
to find the right
session within a cluster.
How do we scale to handle
large traffic spikes?
So, we make use of load balancing.
In Amazon, we've been
using provisioned capacity
from load balancers for many years.
We went to GA earlier this year,
I think in January,
maybe December last year.
We also make use of
autoscaling, previously EC2.
Now, Kubernetes horizontal
pod autoscaling.
Scheduled scaling is also available.
So, broadcasters often know,
or have an idea of, the
size of their audience
based on time of day, program, et cetera.
And we also introduce
CPU utilization buffers.
So, rather than run it, let's
say, at 80% CPU utilization,
maybe you run it at 50%.
You give yourself some
room to handle spikes
that autoscaling simply can't do.
And finally, load shedding.
So, there're several features
in this area for one.
In one case, a customer can choose
to prioritize certain types
of requests over others
because some are more important to them
for revenue than other requests are.
So, I've only touched on part
of what SAS 360 Match can
do and how it does it.
We support many kinds
of client applications.
We use many Amazon services,
and yes, we use ScyllaDB.
So, why do we use ScyllaDB?
ScyllaDB provides the low
latency that we need for reads.
It linearly scales both
vertically and horizontally
with compute.
Individual nodes in the
cluster can be replaced
without data loss or downtime.
The data can be replicated
to multiple data centers,
AZs, or regions, if needed.
And for us, we can also
use workload prioritization
to ensure that ad delivery is not impacted
by other data processing that we must do.
Here is an example of what
a request spike looks like.
So, when we get to a spike
seen on the bottom graph,
there's essentially no
change in read latency,
which is exactly what we wanna see.
What kind of data do we store?
So, we store viewer
data, registration data.
This includes events for event counting,
so we know how many times
you've done something
that's important to the
broadcaster or advertiser.
We also can store exposure,
so this is how many times
you've seen a particular ad,
and there are rules that say things like,
let's not show this ad
more than once a day,
those sorts of things.
Additionally, there is data
that can help map from
one identifier to another,
if necessary.
You could see this for like cases
where you only have a device identifier,
but someone is signing
in as a registered user.
And so, the device becomes associated
with the registered user in the service.
We also make use of additional data,
like the program and episode data,
break identifier data,
product and offer data.
So, it's one thing for me to talk about
what SAS 360 Match can do.
It's another to hear it
from one of our customers.
So, Alex Maison,
head of digital ad platforms
at ITV, says the following:
"The flexibility of
SaaS 360 Match allows us
to develop things at our own pace.
We define our own development queue;
we're not waiting for a third party."
What this means is
that Alex can often use
the existing capabilities
within the toolbox that SAS provides
to solve new problems without
waiting for new development.
All right, if there's just three things
to remember from my presentation,
here's what they are:
With SAS, you can leverage
a multitude of data sources
to make the best decision at the moment.
You can help advertisers
reach their intended audience
and provide broadcasters with the tools
to improve the advertising
experience for viewers.
And SAS does all of this at
a scale that can handle some
of the largest events in broadcast sports.
Alright, I'm gonna turn
this over to Felipe now.
- Thank you so much, Brian,
for such an awesome talk.
Before we let you go, allow me to ask:
We spoke quite extensively
about the SAS 360 suite.
Is there any particular
examples of problems
ScyllDB helps you solve?
- Sure. So, in ScyllDB, I
mentioned event accounts.
So, in one case, a customer
had a satisfaction problem
where viewers were unhappy
that when they went to go
watch a video on-demand stream,
they were shown advertisements.
And let's say they didn't
actually want to watch that one,
they wanted to switch
and watch another one,
and then they get ads again.
Well, why?
There's a way to fix this
within the ad software itself.
So, we can count when
you have last seen ads,
a break, for instance.
And let's say you want to implement a rule
that says if another ad request
comes within four minutes
of the last time you saw ads,
we're gonna skip it, we're
just not gonna do it.
And this greatly improved
user satisfaction
for this broadcaster.
It was a very small change to
make that had a huge impact.
- And from that perspective,
would you say ScyllaDB
somewhat sits in the hot path,
critical path, of your new application?
The way I'd like to frame it is,
ScyllaDB, wherever to come down.
What would be the impact
to your size business?
- Well, Scylla doesn't come down.
- Yeah, (chuckles)
- I mean, it's not a
thing; too much redundancy.
So, Scylla is critical
for us for data redundancy
and ensuring we have the
data we need quickly when
we're trying to make an ad decision,
especially in, like, the
worst case scenarios where
it's a new user, we've not
established a session yet,
and so we plan for those contingencies
and ensure that we have the
resources necessary with Scylla
to answer those requests.
- Well, thank you again, Brian.
Brian will be available
later after our presentation
to answer any questions you may have.
With that, Brian, I'll let you go.
So, during his presentation,
Brian spoke about SAS
360 Match API support
both real-time and batch updates to data.
He also mentioned about one
particular ScyllaDB feature
called workload prioritization.
That's a feature that allow users
to assign different SLA priorities
for different workloads.
In that sense, that's a
feature geared towards
infrastructure consolidation,
which allows you
to prioritize real-time workloads
in contrast with workloads
that do not have strict
latency requirements.
So next up, allow me to call
Sreedhar, VP of Engineering,
and Premkumar, senior
manager at Freshworks,
who are going to share their story on
how Freshworks redesigned
their AI software architecture
for 10 times growth while
improving latency by 95%,
all of which with under
significant cost savings.
Sreedhar and Prem, thank
you again for your time,
and with that, the floor is yours.
- Awesome, thank you Felipe.
Hello everyone. Good morning.
This is Sreedhar Gade, head
of AI and data for Freshworks
and it's Prem, my colleague.
- Hi myself, Premkumar.
I handle the data works at Freshworks,
data platform engineering.
My passion is data and
that's what I live for.
- Fantastic, so over, you
know, next 20, 25 minutes,
I'm going, you know, cover this
presentation in three parts.
I'll call Prem back into the stage,
you know, during the initial part.
Thanks Prem.
So, the first part would
be about the Freshworks.
Essentially we talk about
the company and its scale.
That will be a good segue
into the section two,
which is about the entire
journey of our NoSQL,
you know, the quest to
actually find ScyllaDB
as one of the great partners.
And then, how did we actually
go about building multiple,
you know, use cases, and
then our migration story.
Then I'll come back again
and, you know, wrap up
with the AI use cases and then takeaways.
So, that's us.
And so, Freshworks is a company
started about 15 years ago,
in 2010, in a city
called Chennai in India,
with the dream of building
an uncomplicated software
to enable companies
to solve their business workflows easily.
And we started as a Freshdesk,
which is a customer support software.
And over time, we went on
to build just the dream
that we had about, like,
building uncomplicated software
for all sizes of companies.
And 10 years later, we were
the first company, you know,
in the SaaS field to have
gone public in the US, right?
And we are very proud of that.
And now, we have close
to 75,000 customers,
and we serve our products in
over 40 different languages,
and touching, you know,
distance to 1 billion revenues across.
And we are very proud of that.
And how did we build that?
We always looked at the customer side:
how do we create uncomplicated software?
But at the same time,
we also look at uncomplicated
technology stack.
So, you'll see this is a
foundation at the bottom,
where you have a cloud
infrastructure scaling across.
And then you basically will
have the platform, which is,
you know, all the foundational
capabilities, like,
say, single sign-on, and then
analytics and everything else.
And on top of it, you have,
again, foundational AI,
and then you got the
products on top of it.
So, this helped us
scale leap front bounds,
and we are just getting started.
And the journey has been fabulous for us.
You know, like I said, in 2010,
we started with a
product called Freshdesk.
We were a single-product company,
and with a humble, you know,
a 100 to 200 customers.
But then, soon, we started
adding Freshservice.
Freshservice is our ITSM,
you know, offerings.
And now, today, we have asset management,
and the service management,
and even the employee workflow
management also in this.
And this is one of the
fastest growing, you know,
ITSM systems, you know, on the planet,
you know, on the SaaS world.
And as you can see, we also
have, you know, Freddie,
which is our brand name
for the AI offerings across the company.
And then, you'll hear a lot
about Freddie as well, you know,
in the upcoming slides and outset.
So, that's about Freshworks.
So Freshworks, you know, in a summary,
it's a company that was built
to revolutionize the
experience for SaaS customers.
And we did just that.
But then that also basically
means that we keep reinventing
the data technologies and AI technologies
to meet and exceed customer expectations.
So, let me talk about,
double-click into the
data sort of Freshworks,
like, so one size does not fit all, right?
So, we moved from having entire
business logic into MySQL
or RDBMS to multiple data
technologies across the board,
and, like, whatever actually, you know,
fits that particular use case.
And at the same time,
we wanted to make sure
that whatever we have in
our Dataverse portfolio
is the best-in-best in that space.
And that's where, you
know, our whole partnership
with the ScyllaDB actually comes in,
and that's what we are gonna talk about.
So, we care about data engineering.
So, it's not about operations,
or it's not about keeping
things up and running,
it's not about keep the lights on,
it's about engineering for data.
Second thing is, we care
for reliability at scale.
We spoke about scale already,
and reliability matters.
We at Freshworks, at the Dataverse layer,
we give 4.9 consistently, at
sometimes 4.5-4.9 as well,
for all the products
being supported by that.
We also care about
disaster recovery and BCP,
and also data residency.
The customers as increasingly
more sensitive about
where their data is,
and also, how up and running
in terms of, you know,
the disaster recovery in
case of outages that happen
on the cloud or elsewhere.
And security is paramount for us.
We care for the privacy
and security of our customers' data,
and that's where data,
since the entire Dataverse
holds the source of truth,
as well as the persistence of data.
We want to make sure
that the security is
ground up, data at rest,
data in transit, everything is
kind of encrypted and secure.
Last but not least,
we also have close to
thousand-plus developer community
in the company for us to support,
who build our applications and products
and AI on top of Dataverse.
And we give them AI-enabled
self-service portals
for them to be able to
spin off data layers
and then be able to
scale, support, manage,
deploy, everything else.
So, it's very seamless,
and it actually helps them also scale.
So, that's a glimpse of
Dataverse at Freshworks, right?
Now, going deeper into, you know,
how we came about in our ScyllaDB journey.
So, we have been talking
about Cassandra workloads,
and there are multiple NoSQL
use cases within our company.
You'll hear more about those use cases.
We kind of open up our playbook for you,
in a way selflessly,
to talk more deeper into
exactly what are those use cases
and how it kind of
helped along with scale.
But, in a nutshell,
Scylla kind of, you know,
allowed us to actually
bring our own AWS accounts,
because we are super
complex AWS environment,
already in a mesh architecture
with the platforms, and AI,
and applications.
So, we did not wanna change that.
So, we were actually in our own VPCs,
but actually we could bring
in Scylla into our tech stack,
but still have all the
goodness of hosted solution.
And you'll also see
performance and scale metrics.
You'll see, like I said, use cases.
I think you'll be able to
resonate with some of those
as we speak.
And, but what's more important
is: how did we migrate,
with a third-party Cassandra
or open-source Cassandra to
where the Scylla is, right?
And, like, how was the
journey? You'll also see that.
And last but not least,
there are also some
future upcoming use cases
that we are talking about.
You know, this world is all about AI.
So, everything to do with AI,
and how we are empowering
it using self-service
or agentic workflows,
how Scylla is going to actually
help us get there, right?
Like I said, our customers
care for data residency
and that's one of the reasons where,
while we use a managed service,
the entire data plane
is within our own VPC.
We have full control over it,
and then we have full access to it,
and then it is actually
within the boundary
of our security guardrails.
And the control plane is with Scylla,
and there's a perfect
combination, you know,
and it really helped us
quickly deploy, quickly scale,
and take it from there.
And this is, I think, a defining slide,
because if you look at the numbers there,
when we actually did the benchmark,
when the executives from Scylla
came and met us in Chennai
and said, "Hey, you know,
we are this company,
and we actually solved
Cassandra problems."
I said like," Hey, this problem
is already been solved."
Apparently not.
So, when we actually looked at it,
and they did the benchmarks,
and I were like, we were
just blown away with the,
especially, you know, tail,
you know, the performance,
is like much, much higher.
It, like, you know, P99.99,
you know, percentile, right?
We generally look at P90, P95;
here we are looking at that depth,
which means that no single
request is actually,
like, left behind in
terms of the performance.
So, that was our experience.
And, so with this,
I basically, like, can hand over to Prem,
to actually walk us through
some of the use cases.
You can actually go through
it, and then I'll come back
and wrap it up.
Prem, over to you.
- Thank you sir.
- Yeah,
- I'm gonna talk about some of
the use cases at Freshworks.
We use ScyllaDB.
So, I'm gonna cover three different types
of database migrations
as well along with this.
So, the first one will be
covering Cassandra to ScyllaDB,
which is a natural migration
for us to consider.
And the second one will be,
like, how can MySQL data
to be moved towards ScyllaDB?
And the third one will be DynamoDB data,
with limitations kind of improved
while we move towards ScyllaDB.
So, Conversation Store is a
platform service at Freshworks.
This kind of covers all
the conversations, kind
of stores all the product
conversations at one shell,
and then this kind of also
as translation service,
this can also be useful for us
to store the AI conversations
between customer and AI agents.
And this is powered by Cassandra.
And we also have UCR,
which we call as unified customer portal.
Like, we kind of actually store
all the contacts, whatever
that is part of all these products,
like Freshdesk and Freshservice,
in one place.
And we also retrieve it on
a very low latency level.
So that's a requirement.
So, we were using Cassandra for this.
There were some bottlenecks in that,
and also some availability issues.
So, we did consider
ScyllaDB for that as well.
And as I said, the scale is kind
of 4 billion-plus contacts
saved in this portal,
and the expectation is
very minimal, right?
The latency should be
below 5ms consistently,
like, it should be even P99.99
should be also below 5ms.
And the current scale is 15K
ops per second in this portal.
So, I'm gonna walk through
the migration story.
And as I said,
we had some difficulties in
Cassandra, like, every weekend,
whenever repairs runs, deletion runs,
we add fall into some latencies,
and also timeouts in Cassandra.
And also, we did try some
third-party Cassandras
like DataStax.
There was some availability issues.
So, we did consider ScyllaDB
for this particular action.
And I'm gonna walk through
the migration story,
which is kind of a
little interesting for us
and also challenging for
us to push our limits,
because we want to do
this in a live migration,
because we wanted to give
the customer the ease
of continuing the use of database
and applications even on the weekends.
So we cannot afford any downtime
and that's our benchmark.
We wanted to, you know, make
sure the customer is always up
and able to serve, because we serve across
all part of the country, right?
And also, all part of the world.
So customers, we kind of push
our standards that we ensure
that there is a zero
downtime migration always.
And we kind of taken
the first complication
and introduced ZDM proxy
in the middle of Cassandra,
which can actually do dual reads for us,
for both Cassandra and Scylla.
So, while it does dual reads,
the reads goes through Cassandra,
that's our existing system.
So, when I say dual
reads, all the new data,
like when, right from the beginning
of the ZDM proxy gets
captured in both the places,
Cassandra and Scylla.
And now that CDM migrator comes
to migrate the historical
data, like, from where it left.
So, we started dual reads.
Now we have to migrate the historical data
into the new system, ScyllaDB.
So, we used the CDM migrator.
We migrated all the
historical data into ScyllaDB.
And now that it has both historical data
and the latest data through
dual reads from the ZDM.
And this is very well put
out here as well, like,
how the CDM migrator reads data,
and then pushes to ScyllaDB.
And, after we complete the migration,
we also wanted to validate,
and then fix the missing gaps
in terms of repairs and things.
So, we kind of actually
use the CDM migrator
to validate all the data is copied
from Cassandra to Scylla.
So, while we do that, we
find some of the gaps,
because the data we talk
here is close to terabytes,
like 1.2 terabytes to be exact,
and we find some bottlenecks,
and job is keep on running for a while.
And then we kind of took the
open-source CDM migrator,
modified with batch processing options.
This helps us to kind of
add the batch processing
and improve the time to 10X.
So, one advantage what
we have in this portal
and this use case is,
this only powers majority of
inserts, not much are updated.
So, which we can make sure
that only if we check
the record exists or not,
that should be enough for us to cross
through the validation phase.
So, we were able to get 10X improvement.
And now the CDM migrator
is substreamed as well,
and ScyllaDB is using for other customers,
while they migrate
Cassandra to Scylla as well.
And as I said, validation
is completed now.
We also go to kind of we wanted
to switch the traffic right?
And we kind of switch the traffic
from, I think I moved this slide.
Yeah, we kind of switch the traffic
from Cassandra to Scylla at this point.
Now, while we do that,
we want to ensure the
reads are switched first,
and then validated through
logs for any errors,
or any timeouts, and things like that.
While we are comfortable,
then we kind of move the right
traffic also to ScyllaDB.
And we also ensure that,
after the write is switched,
some kind of ZDM proxy dual reads happens
to Cassandra as well,
because that gives us the
convenience and comfortness for us
to come back to Cassandra if
there is any issues faced.
But fortunately, there's just one path,
once we moved to Scylla, there
is no coming back for us,
because the system was
scaling what we expected
and, you know, we were able
to always save the traffic
within the SLA.
And the tail latencies
were really helpful,
like, Steve mentioned initially.
And I move on to the next use case.
This is Workflow Automator use case.
So, when I say Workflow Automator,
this is spun up of our all the workflows
that runs across our
systems, all the products
and all the platforms
services, all the AI use cases.
So, this is a bound use case with Scylla.
There's no migration involved here.
The Scylla was directly supporting this.
And the uniqueness is, this
our multiple concurrency,
and we have close to 250k-plus
workflows stored here,
and parallel executions has to happen.
And this is operating on the
top of Netflix Conductor,
the open-source software that
demands a Cassandra backend.
So, we kind of selected Scylla
because the throughput is very high,
and now AI coming into
picture, there's a lot
of even more further workflows
that has to be run
seamlessly and optimized.
So, we selected ScyllaDB for this use case
and it is being served
very, very much in ease,
and also within the latency as he said.
Yeah, so moving on to the next one.
So, I've covered the
Cassandra to ScyllaDB story,
now I'm coming towards
what we wanted to migrate
from MySQL to ScyllaDB.
So Freshworks historically
is a MySQLcumRuby store.
So, we say the source
of truth lies in MySQL.
So, while we say that, I mean we are able
to handle the scale today,
because we are able to,
we are always thinking about
handling next five years
what can happen and
what will be the scale,
and we want to see to that
this scale has to be supported
as I said, without any downtime,
and without any customer latencies,
and without any,
with all the new features
coming up with the AI,
and things like that.
We want to deep archive
So, we thought to move
the text and BLOB data,
that is saved in MySQL today,
and that takes close to 2
petabytes of data for us,
because all the historical
conversations logs
in conversations store,
but again, the tickets
and ticket bodies data lies in the MySQL
at this point of time.
So, we felt this is only a lookup content,
there is no filtering or
anything on the top of this.
So, this can move to a different store.
We evaluated multiple stores
for this particular operations
and this particular use case,
and we finally felt a ScyllaDB
is again offering this low latency,
and also due to the
reliability, and availability,
and scalability options which they have.
We felt this can also fit into ScyllaDB.
And while I talk,
the problem which we face
today in MySQL is we want
to upgrade the systems pretty often,
like six months from today,
because of the year-old kind of situation.
And, to migrate this petabytes
of data without downtime
is becoming more, and more challenging.
And whenever there's increased
workloads from customers,
like, you know, they wanted to
process some historical jobs
and they wanted to process
historical contents,
and due to some Cyber Monday
deals, the traffic increases.
We will have to scale it on the ease.
And all this becomes little complicated
in the relational database world,
but this is what is Scylla
gonna help us in benefiting.
So, there are two advantages.
So, we kind of bring the
MySQL storage lesser,
which means we can handle the MySQL store
with more further ease-ness,
and also we can scale up,
scale down replication,
and all that will happen within the SLA.
And on the other end, like,
where the majority data is
gonna shift towards Scylla,
we can actually scale
seamlessly, vertically,
horizontally, in however fashion we want.
And also do version upgrades,
patching without any downtime.
So, this is advantage we see.
And while we see that, we also wanted
to migrate the petabytes of data, right?
And it's not gonna be a direct option.
And we have the same challenges,
like, incremental data,
and also the historical data migration
that has to be done here.
And while I say that,
we kind of selected
Kafka approach for this,
for the CDC changes,
the incremental changes.
And then the historical data
comes through Parquet format.
So, we like talk about
this, I also need to,
yes, so we need to do 2
petabytes of data migration here,
as I already said.
And we kind of use Kafka Connect,
Debezium-backed CDC options from MySQL.
This will copy the bin logs
into Kafka through events,
and then save all these
incremental changes.
And that can be put into a ScyllaDB
through ScyllaDB Stream Store.
So, this will actually,
again, part of the Kafka
Connect built by Scylla's team.
This Sink Connector will
actually read all the data
from Kafka and pushes
to Scylla seamlessly.
So, the incremental data comes in,
and from MySQL, we will use the
S3 export option to Parquet,
and then Parque files can be
loaded into Scylla directly.
And then we'll validate using
our custom Lambda solution so
that the data present seamlessly,
and we'll switch the
read traffic initially
to make sure that the
read things are happening
and processed fine with
the Scylla systems,
and then we'll switch the
write traffic seamlessly.
So that's the plan we have.
And I've already covered MySQL use case
and the Cassandra use case.
Moving on to the Dynamo use case.
Today, our activities, microservices,
it sits on the top of Dynamo.
So, let's see activities,
it's another use case.
Use case number three,
which we actually see,
some limitations because
of the size, right?
You know, the item size in
Dynamo is limited to 400 kb,
which is actually pushing
us to, you know, split it,
and then write it into Dynamo suite.
Dynamo is fine, that's completely cool,
it's great to use as well.
But again, this limitation
pushes into multiple options,
like, we'll have to split
it into multiple records,
and then write it, and
then search it again.
All these logics are handling
some compute throttling
in our compute layer.
So, we wanted to see if we
can migrate this to Scylla,
because the limitations
are not there as such.
And also, we wanted to scale this further
and also be FedRAMP-compliant
and things in the future.
So, we selected this particular option.
And for this, again, we thought to migrate
both historical data as well
as the incremental data.
A pretty much same approach like MySQL,
but different connectors are used here.
So, we kind of enabled
the Dynamo Streams here.
So, Dynamo Streams will actually
have the change data capture
in Dynamo, and from there,
we kind of actually use our custom Lambda
to read these events from
DybamoDB and push to Kafka events.
So, this will actually take care
of the incremental changes,
as we already said.
And this incremental changes
will be taken to ScyllaDB,
like, using the same Sink Connector
that is provided by Scylla team itself.
And then data receipt
in Scylla at this point.
And the historical data will be taken
from the Spark job this time.
we'll run a Spark map
produce and copy the data
from historical data
from Dynamo to ScyllaDB.
And then move the traffic to Scylla, like,
the way same switch, like read and write.
So, this is well called
out here in four phases.
The first phase covers
migrating the schema
from Dynamo to ScyllaDB,
and then we'll also
enable the dynamo streams,
as I said, that's what is
called ODC/CDC/Dual writes.
So, this will take the data to Kafka,
and from Kafka we'll
have to take it to Scylla
that is covered in the
phase two and phase three.
And then, we'll also cover the
check sync validation, right?
That will happen through
our custom Lambda.
And then, we'll have to do the read
and write switch periodically.
So, with this, I hand it over to Sree,
to cover the next feature
use cases at ScyllaDB
for Freshworks.
Thank you.
Thank you Sree.
- Alright, thanks Prem.
So, just to wrap it up, it's
not just the traditional MySQL,
or, you know, these use cases,
but we are going forward,
we are going to, you know,
have more, like, doubling down on AI.
So, what are the different use
cases you're talking about?
So, there are two specific use cases
that we are looking at going forward.
One is something called, you know,
we are talking about,
like a Feature Store where
essentially, like, most of
your features, most of your,
you know, the use cases
are trying to reach LLMs.
In some cases, trying to reach agents.
So, all these conversations
are kind of on a cached
in ScyllaDB.
So that way, your traffic
between the, you know your app
and the LLMs are actually kind of reduced.
Essentially, the overall
round trips depend upon
the performance of LLM as well.
And when you make multiple
calls that kind of will be,
like, a very noticeable latency.
So, this is one caching use
case that we are looking at.
So basically, ultra-low
predictable, you know, latency.
And the second one is,
we are talking about, like,
a feature caching as well.
So yeah, this is the one I
was just talking about where,
you know, how do you,
so this is basically,
in between you and the LLM essentially.
So, this is something we
are here to experiment,
and we are hoping
that I think we'll see
some good improvement here.
Next one is the data source for modeling.
So, this is more like an MLOps use case.
So, Freshworks has two sets of models
that we use in an AI use case.
One is a generative AI,
where we do not do any kind
of training, we just go,
this is Azure OpenAI and a few other ones.
These are the large language models.
We don't do any training, we
just do inference with them.
But we also have self-hosted models.
There are smaller models where
they're kind of optimized
for some kind of a very specific use cases
in industry verticals that we have.
It's like, something
like ITSM or FaceDesk.
So, these are the ones
that we kind of train them
and these training
cycles are becoming more,
and more frequent, and when
we are working with this,
we are also looking at to see,
can we actually have, you know, ScyllaDB,
like, you know, in the training pipeline.
So that way, Prem spoke
about 2 petabytes of data,
and all the data needs
to actually go into
this training pipeline.
So how do we actually kind
of do some kind of caching
to speed this up, right?
So, and in the future,
we are talking about, like
notification services,
we are talking about URL
shortening, this is again,
the 75,000 customers that we have.
We lead customers who
have customer domains,
and, you know, create
their own custom URLs.
So, in that space, you know,
how do we actually use ScyllaDB
to create URL shortening services as well,
and then attachment services.
So yeah, essentially, all
the products that we have,
you know, the fundamentally
they are ticketing solutions,
and they'll also have ticket
bodies and attachments.
So, until now we are looking
at, you know, the MySQL alone,
but then, you know, can
we actually use this
as attachment service as well.
So ultimate takeaways.
So, as you have seen,
Freshworks always
reinvents the technology,
you know, every single
year, full stack, right?
Whether it's a cloud layer,
storage, compute, network, data,
or it's the platform layer,
we are talking about multiple
capabilities, like email,
analytics, and you know, single sign-on,
or the AI, or the products.
And Scylla has been our partner
in actually building some
of the cool technologies,
and they have been
actually co-build partners
and co-market partners as well.
So, we achieved, I think, 10X
of what we thought initially
that we would otherwise do.
So, it's always like, you know,
awesome working with them.
So, with that, I'm calling
Felipe at the stage.
- Thank you so much Sree.
You guys basically did
all the value ScyllaDB
gives to Freshworks.
One particular question I have to you is,
since you guys are running Scylla cloud,
and Prem spoke briefly
about ScyllaDB cloud
and your BYOA setup,
what's the main value BYOA gives to you
as a customer, and for
your customers as well?
Because in the BYOA setup,
all the data is issue under
your own management as well.
Could you speak a bit more about that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think, bring your own
account matters a lot,
especially, we are talking about,
so Freshworks serves our products
in five different regions,
like us, Europe, India,
Australia, and Middle East.
And when we speak about
customers also care
for data residency, so they look at
where their data resides
and how it gets transferred.
So, we wanna make sure
all of our sub-processors,
also live in the same region
and the data doesn't go out
the storage or in transit.
So keeping all this in mind,
when we are talking about
bringing your own account,
essentially our entire data
plan decide within our account.
So that actually makes it
very easy in terms of access
scaling for our own engineers, right?
And that could be a deal breaker for us.
And since you enabled
us with that feature,
it made it so seamless
for us to, you know,
do the entire migration over to ScyllaDB.
- Prem also spoke quite
extensively about migrations
and the different
strategies you guys took.
And I don't want to choose sugar-coat it,
I mean database migrations are hard.
We often classify, we like to
describe migration database
like an open-heart surgery.
How did ScyllaDB help it
and simplify the process
of migrating across multiple
databases to ScyllaDB?
How did your support team
working with you guys
and helping you guys throughout
all these steps involved
to move your data over?
- Yeah, yeah.
No, I think the analogy
of operating on a patient
is actually perfect.
But we are operating on a patient
where a patient is still in all the senses
and actually not, you know,
like, you know, on an
anesthesia or anything else.
So, our customers expect us
not to go down at any point.
They don't care whether
you are doing maintenance
or upgrades.
They want the service to be
up and running all the time.
And that's one of the best
features of ScyllaDB, right?
So, we could do hot, hot scenario where
while the upgrades are happening
or migration is happening,
we could do parallel writes,
like Prem just spoke about it,
and then reads progressively.
We kind of shifted based on the accuracy
as we get more confidence.
So that way, but if it is RDBMS,
at least you'll have like in
a few seconds of downtime.
- Yeah.
- And that is noticeable,
you know, for our customers.
And then, every time there is a downtime,
we gotta notify 75,000
customers two weeks in advance.
And then if somebody says no,
then in some cases premium customers
you might have to even move the window.
So, in this case, it's like
you're trying to maintain
or replace engines of aircraft
while it is still flying.
- Yeah, thank you so much, Sreedhar,
and thank you so much, Prem.
I would like to tell you thank you
for your continued partnership,
and I hope we will help you out
with this upcoming use case.
- So, with that folks-
- Thank you so much.
- I would like to thank
you well for attending
and listening to both
of our speakers today.
If you like what we had to
share, please remember to rate
our talk in the AWS events app.
And with that, if in case you
have any questions to Brian,
or to Sree, or Prem, we would
love to catch you up here.
And you are also welcome
to visit our booth,
at the Venetian Boot, 1747.
Thank you folks, and have a great day.